dans le groupe à
je suis pas fils tu six mois owen on
sait pas où après que je vous dise voilà
c'est shakespeare baffie oui maintenant
attention vous pensez à quoi là à
l'instant au plaisir d'être avec vous en
ce jour et on va les laisser et c'est
vrai que ce que tu sais pas c'est très
décontracté l'ambiance mais très bien je
suivrai toujours vraiment je suis ravi
qu'il soit ravi qu'elle soit ravi
suivant quand vous étiez petit vous
auriez aimé ressemble et actif à la fée
clochette
la grève affectait mais j'aurais voulu
ressembler à sim gens prendre chez mark
valois ou alors à elie semoun suffit
proches quand avez vous pleuré pour la
dernière fois il n'y a pas très
longtemps
sur scène oui oui le spectacle dôme qui
présentait sa compte alors je me suis
laissé aller dans le personnage moncany
oui et ça se voit que changeriez vous en
vous si vous aviez une baguette magique
pourquoi j'aimerais bien qu'il faut
bleus l'enseignant mes livres le ferais
bleus voilà tout entier quel est le
péché qui vous tente le plus l'appareil
ah bon oui comme tous les gens sur
actifs et qu'elle sur l'écran qu'est ce
que vous diriez depuis négatif sur vous
ça fait parce vous savez pas choisir ma
chemise il faut dire que vous étiez et
que je baise le tout ce qui peut être
médiatisé moi c'est mon enveloppe
charnelle
on a l'impression que c'est quelqu'un de
dur sensible je crois que c'est ça qui
avez vous le plus envie d'épater ou amen
qu'avez-vous fait que nous ne sachions
pas là plein de choses
justement bien le dire en face à ses
fins qu'est-ce que j'ai c'est du cinéma
non ça va sortir l'excusé avec florent
pagny france à qui l'ol c'est une super
expérience
je veux savez moi je trouve autre chose
j'ai chanté une fois sur scène avec jean
claude dreyfus
ah oui oui je sais on arrive maintenant
la question jacques chancel a series et
c'est quoi le principe
et dieu dans tout ça les bonnes c'est
bien s'il reste à sa place et moi la
mienne
ah bon à ce mois là ouais ouais ils
comptent pas se déplacer de trois jours
fraga
du balai
on va terminer a review on ne bouge pas
à armes égales
[Musique]
c'est bien vous êtes gérant moment ça a
été moi je suis ravi anouk vous pensez à
quoi en ce moment là et à vous lasser
tac au tac
quand vous vous regardez le matin dans
le miroir vous vous dites quoi je me
regarde mais je mets pas de lunettes
ça va quand elle vous pleurez pour la
dernière fois
j'espérais ya pas tellement longtemps
j'ai vu un programme je crois sur arte
sur des enfants palestiniens et
israéliens
les deux mois à moi je sais pas et qui
est évidemment là où ils étaient et ils
ont passé une journée tous ensemble ils
ont joué comme des mômes et après ils
sont rentrés chez eux et après les
gosses ont dit ce terrible quand on sera
grand va peut-être se tuer ça ça m'a
complètement cette source
samarraï le môme était super formidable
c'était des mots quoi c'était pareil et
ça m'a bouleversé se plaît à dire si la
vie était referiez quoi pas pareil
peut-être que je serai consciente
malheureuse ou que l'argent a quand même
une certaine importance jamais fait
attention à l'argent fou quand même qui
peut faire attention
peut-être sinon j'ai pas trop à me
plaindre si vous restez 24 heures à
vivre feriez quoi pendant ces 24 heures
donc je pars tout de suite
ahoua n'doli parce que gagner un jour
qu'est ce que la vie vous a appris la
tolérance
j'ai posé la question chancel pour finir
ses traditionnels et dieu dans tout ça
je crois qu'en ce moment il doit être
parti en vacances
vous pensez à quoi alors en ce moment là
je pense vraiment sincèrement je suis en
train de me demander si j'ai eu raison
de venir dans cette émission je pense
que oui pour l'instant quand vous vous
regardez le matin la glace vous dites
quoi
je n'aime pas me regarder le matin dans
la glace je déteste mon image je déteste
me regarder à la télé je déteste me
regarder sur un écran c'est non non je
n'aime pas du tout ça mais je crois
qu'il a beaucoup de gens qui font de la
télé qui sont comme ça quand vous étiez
petit vous auriez aimé ressembler à qui
à bout pourquoi moi parce que je
regardais déjà la télé quand avez vous
pleuré pour la dernière fois je pleure
très souvent mais alors là ça moi c'est
vraiment devant devant un film devant un
film bien foutu ou changeriez quoi en
vous si vous aviez une baguette magique
à part votre pub
[Applaudissements]
voulez vous dire de plus négatif sur
vous je pense que j'ai pas de talent
voilà je pense que je suis un gros
bosseur mais je pense que j'ai aucun
talent vous n'avez pas de dons mais du
talent oui parce que quand on réussit
c'est quand même du talent vous feriez
quoi s'il ne vous restait que 24 heures
à vivre l'amour pendant 24 heures
ouais tu sais j'ai envie de faire
l'amour pendant 24 ans oui pourquoi pas
autant essayer c'est avec du viagra et
plusieurs personnes
voilà qu'avez-vous fait jean marc
morandini que nous ne sachions pas
c'est pas tout ce qui est ma vie privée
vous ne la connaissez pas et je pense
que c'est mieux comme ça
une bonne oeuvre une bonne action ouais
mais ça se dit pas ça en fait
moi j'aime pas les gens qui vont à la
télé pour raconter leurs bonnes oeuvres
moi j'en fais mais je les garde pour moi
une mauvaise action plein acheter que
les chaussures
décidément on va faire une hardy view
alors dos vous pensez à quoi en ce
moment là je suis légèrement déstabilisé
pourquoi le début peut-être parce que
dans la loge de maquillage est arrivé
derrière moi
auront ils la poussent un cri strident
on aurait dit un corbeau je sais comment
le vendeur j'étais tellement content de
le voir mais il est content aussi ma
blessure il s'est dit gêné viennent que
s'il ya baffie le régime s'y attendait
vraiment cet accent horrible union gtu
10 mois orlando à qui vous auriez aimé
ressembler quand vous étiez petit
orlando brad pitt ce n'était pas mal
mais je préférais voilà quand avez vous
pleuré pour la dernière fois je pense
que je suis de plus en plus émotif
voilà donc une chanson une voix quel
artiste aujourd'hui vous caler tout
connu quel artiste que vous pouvez vous
tirer des larmes hollande aujourd'hui
record
[Applaudissements]
new york d'origine celle incluant
l'année alors vous changeriez quoi on
joue là comme ça aujourd'hui si vous
aviez une baguette magique d'avoir tout
de suite comme sa première avoir 20
centimètres de plus ou quel est le
cliché qui vous manque le plus kim est
entré plus tu te séduire de pouvoir
obtenir la personne que nous ne voudrais
pas c'est à dire 'voilà ce sera
d'obtenir un délai de trois péchés qui
rôdent en ce moment là de temps en temps
ou et vous savez plus fous de plusieurs
fois dans la journée de régates et de
s'évader fait légal comme on dit qu'est
ce que vous pourriez dire orlando de
plus négatif sur vous donc il faut
courir vraiment la colère ouais je suis
quelqu un tel qu'un hollande ou galets
l'insultent ce qui vous a fait le plus
mal
en fait je pense que je suis quelqu'un
de feu mais c'est difficile et ce tour
mais profondément honnête voilà des
comptes comme doute de ma parole vous
conduire avec quelqu'un vous a traité d'
escroc un jour là bas c'est une chance
des malhonnêtes c'est la chose qui
pourrait vraiment mettre blessant très
mal aux biens hollande ou quand le
téléphone sonne est ce que vous êtes
heureux ou agacé est ce que tu vas
personnaliser la sonnerie de portable
est ce que c'est une chanson de ta soeur
quand ça sonne ça fait quoi quand comme
souvent elle se serait il venait d'avoir
18 ans orlando
vous feriez quoi si vous restez 24
heures à vivre car et de changer la
vitre je sais pas j'ai serré de de
mettre tout en ordre avant que je parte
je suis quelqu'un de magna je suis
maniaque de l'ordre vendredi à douala et
je pense que je ne serai tout pour que
les gens apprennent que je partais
chacun une finale ça s'adresse à voilà
il y avait cette affaire et s'il y avait
ça reste assez loin et toi tu ferais
quoi la cites rester 24 heures à vivre
j'irai tout ranger chez orlando
vad
dans le tour de la question j'ai déjà
répondu ouais on a une maison à crédit
ça me rassure un petit crédit sur 15 ans
ça me ferait du bien orlando et dieu
dans tout ça
dieu dieu il est là dit je sers il faut
qu'on soit honnête parce qu'on s'arrange
il existe surtout quand on a besoin de
lui voilà dieu est au mathis par tous
les soirs
un hardi view
vous pensez à quoi là je me dis merde
pourquoi est ce que je pensais échapper
à ce genre de trucs ouais vous dites
quoi le matin quand vous regardez dans
le miroir je me dis bon encore une
commence en a qu à se dire qu'on a de la
chance vous auriez aimé ressembler à qui
quand vous êtes les petit petit petit à
spiderman quelle insulte qui vous a fait
le plus mal
le temps n'existe pas de conneries ça
fait un petit moment en ont peut-être
que c'est des trucs là que je lis en ce
moment dans la presse quand il ya des
gens qui comprennent pas le film ça
m'énerve à moi j'ai vu que des bons
papiers sur le film il ya eu un truc qui
m'a énervé
les gens disent il ya un mec qui a écrit
que le sud était chip et je les prie
pour moi quand avez vous pleuré pour la
dernière fois dans le berry ouais
dans une scène mais pour le rôle oui oui
pour le roi mais sinon on devrait aller
aux jeux réponse que je vois un accord
il changerait quoi en vous si vous aviez
une baguette magique un peu moins d'ego
ouais ouais bah ouais c'est vrai les
rêves leurs trains quel est le péché qui
vous tente le plus la luxure ouais avec
ta femme rejette qui avez vous le plus
envie d'épater
déjà moi ouais ouais
quelle est la dernière chose que vous
faites le soir avant de vous coucher une
petite brunette au dégoût un qui pense
qu'à toi mais même lui tu vois donc
finalement c'est très rassurant pour le
reste de l'humanité les gens le
comprennent mal je ne le mets deal avec
monica bellucci sa style qu'il ya un
problème énorme
vincent que pourriez-vous dire depuis
négatif sur vous qui vient de faire ses
vraies bonnes réponses
qu'est ce que je pourrais dire de plus
négatif sur moi là tout de suite
ouais t'es vraiment à chier dans
blueberry vous n'êtes pas d'accord ça me
fait plaisir
si votre vie était à refaire vous
changeriez quoi mais pour le moment pas
grand chose mais c'est vrai quand on
voit vos films le peu de femmes c'est
vrai qu'on se dit dans le fond n'y a pas
de ça vient des problèmes
un des points faibles des trucs tu le
sais bien
non mais j'ai un mot et qu'avez-vous
fait vincent que nous ne sachions pas
alors justement restons-en là démentie
durant cette interview
bien sûr que non vous pensez à quoi en
ce moment là je sens à votre prochain
invité
quand vous vous regardez dans la glace
le matin vous vous dites quoi
je vois mon père
de plus en plus et tu te dis quoi ton
père dans la glace je lui dis mais je
peut s'écouter morts et dix non j'suis
pas bon
vous auriez aimé ressembler à qui quand
vous étiez petit comme bonjour ressemble
à mon père voilà votre plus belle
histoire d'amour c'est laquelle
l'histoire de musique de mon épouse
trudie quand avez vous pleuré pour la
dernière fois au entend de la musique et
pleuré comme un jeu plus facilement ses
seins et grand talent vous changeriez
quoi en vous si vous aviez une baguette
magique au moins d'argent peut-être à
gauche à radio web
j'aimerais bien avoir votre esprit c'est
gentil
kaehlin clichy qui vous tente le plus
vaste bâtisse bad
non non mais ce n'est pas propre
qu'est ce que vous pourriez dire de plus
négatif sur vous si votre vie était à
refaire qu'est-ce que vous changeriez
rien
quelle est l'insulté qui vous a fait le
plus mal
awana tre insultes lorsque les vrais ça
faisait mal
vous n'êtes pas prête je n'ai pas mal de
me confesser i'm looking les hobbits la
cuisse à nha trang peut que feriez vous
s'il ne vous restait que 24 heures à
vivre mais claf faire l'amour et le sexe
24 il a fait l'amour avec sa femme
pendant huit heures une fois émoi 12h et
que tu as faim
singh avez vous déjà pensé à vous
suicider parce que quand ça va trop bien
comme ça jamais non j'aime trop la vie
pour penser à ça
à une hardy view quand vous regardez le
matin à glace vous dites quoi
je trouve que lesdits matin je me trouve
assez en forme et d'autres pas du tout
ouais vous auriez aimé ressembler à qui
quand vous étiez petit jet pas je vais
poser la question je
j'avais envie de l'habitat y croirons de
free j'ai envie de faire de faire tout
gt gt boulimique jeu j'ai fait mon ce
métier parce que je j'ai adoré daniel
gélin gérard philipe fred astaire raimu
harry baur enfin je veux dire que j'ai
pas voulu ressembler à quelqu'un je
voulais avoir la possibilité de me
multiplier et d'être tout et tout et
tout le monde quoi vous avez pleuré
quand pour la dernière fois je pleure
pas mal moi je plonge à cga l'âme
sassine
je pleure je parle je trouve que je te
connais entouré de choses tellement
monstrueuse que je crois qu'il est
difficile de ne pas pleurer quelques
fois sur ce que nous représentons nous
les hommes
vous diriez quoi depuis négatif sur vous
que je manque de jeu peut-être pas au
bout des choses que je me reproche
souvent de ne pas aller au bout des
choses sur votre carrière par exemple
vous pensez que j'aurais pu faire une
plus grande carrière
en fait j'ai réussi ce que je voulais
depuis le départ inconsciemment c'est à
dire faire ce métier en m'amusant
bonjour en gardant le l'envi le faire et
en rencontrant le plus de monde possible
qui me passionne voilà si si votre vie
était à refaire qu'est-ce que vous ne le
feriez pas de la même façon trop mon
dieu je sais pas je regrettais rien en
fait
non non non je vous dois t'on rien je
les jours doit être que ça se termine un
jour si quand même aujourd'hui qui avez
vous le plus envie d'épater mes enfants
mes enfants ma femme
enfin les gens que j'aime j'adore quand
même temps gelé quand je les ai pas tant
commente la presse qu est la dernière
chose que vous faites le soir avant de
vous coucher
j'essaye un type à claquettes sur la
moquette pour voir si le rappelle
toujours c'est vrai alors oui oui c'est
bien gentil rouge le jaune voisins et
puisqu'on apprend vierge quand on sent
bien que le sol et qu'est ce que la vie
vous a appris on apprend à vivre tout
simplement
elle vous apprend à vivre est-ce que
vous avez une meilleure opinion de vous
aujourd'hui qu'à l'âge de 20 ans oui
nettement nettement
vous avez menti là durant cette
interview je ne crois pas alors j'avais
envie de vous faire une hardy view mais
comme c'est vous je vous faire une
entière d'idiot
alors il va vous ne pensez pas quoi en
ce moment je pense pas que je suis en
train de regarder des conneries à la
télévision dans mon canapé puisque je
suis dedans quand vous regardez le matin
dans la glace vous ne vous dit jamais
quoi je me dis jamais que j'aimerais
être sarkozy en train de me dire que je
veux être président de la république ça
c'est sûr vous n'auriez pas aimé
ressembler à qui quand vous étiez petits
à qui j'aurais pas aimé ressembler pour
l'été petit aux truands qui voulaient
flinguer gary cooper dans le train
sifflera trois fois
qu'est-ce que vous ne quittez riez pas
pour le grand amour
la grande amitié
quand on vous demande une autographes
vous ne signez jamais quoi thierry
ardisson dakhla vous garderiez coise en
vous si vous aviez une baguette magique
ben la baguette magique
quel est le péché qui vous tente le
moins l'avarice
ouais je pourriez vous dire de plus
positif sur vos dans une discussion
j'aime bien que les autres aient raison
comme ça j'apprends quelque chose si
votre vie était à refaire vous ne
changeriez pas quoi la liberté que j'ai
aujourd'hui dans ma vie et dans mon
boulot qui n'avez vous jamais eu envie
d'épater joe cooker je vous fais parce
que c'est un chanteur génial et je
préfère que celui qui continue à mes
pattes et falker
quelle est la chose que vous ne faites
jamais avant de vous coucher vers un
pyjama
ah oui non et et le diable dans tout ça
c'est un ami exigeant qu'est ce qui ne
vous énerve pas du tout chez moi votre
cravate
qu'est-ce que vous avez pas dans les
cloches la vérité qu'est ce que la vie
ne nous a toujours pas après la méfiance
comment n'aimeriez vous pas mourir en
ayant peur de mourir
qui auriez vous aimé ne pas voir ici ce
soir
j'imagine si j'aurais pas aimé voir ici
ce soir je sais pas vraiment les gens
qui pensent que tu avais pas d'avion sur
le pentagone le 11 septembre enfin n'est
pas passée mois alors que blanc risque
il faudra vérifier
faut-il être quelqu'un d'autre que soi
même
bah parfois vous enseigner quelque chose
un oui à quel signe reconnaissez-vous
infailliblement l'intelligence la
gentillesse il ya une belle bande de
contrat
existe-t-il une personne que vous
agissiez au point de souhaiter de
survivre pinochet
[Musique]
alors françoise vous pensez à quoi en ce
moment là je pense avoue thierry
vraiment pourquoi vous êtes plein
grimace avec votre bouche la régression
c'est ça oui j'ai remarqué qu'il a des
dents particulièrement étincelant
non vous pensez vous parce que des
conneries comme ça c'est le moment le
plus crucial dans l'émission il a loupé
je pensais à quoi la met à vous et à
votre sourire colgate et valverde par
contre quand vous regardez le matin dans
un miroir vous vous dites quoi
non mais j'ai un miroir vraiment j'ai
déménagé et pas très longtemps et le
miroir on voit rien donc ça va et en
plus comme j'ai pas mes lunettes je vois
encore moins bien les choses
donc je ne me dit rien parce que sa
peine attention donc je vois pas vous
auriez met à ressembler à quelqu'un vous
étiez petit ressembler à qui quand
j'étais petit mais figurez vous que je
collectionnais des photos d'actrice est
la première actrice que j'ai trouvé
d'une beauté sublime c'était marina
vlady elle était belle et je crois
qu'elle est toujours resté très très
bien
à oui puis à une bardot bien sûr et ma
mère qui m'avait acheté une
une robe en vichy rose qui ne m'allait
pas du tout c'est une catastrophe comme
je vais essayer vous soyez prête à tout
quitter pour le grand amour non non
parce que le grand amour est derrière
moi
on pensait pas qu'on puisse se mettre
deux fois dans sa vie a gênés plus que
deux fois dans ma vie à sa première
annonce mais ça tout le monde le sait on
plus je suis jean marie périer
un bel acteur anglais mais ça fait trois
ans qu'on va faire je n'ai jamais jamais
pas joué ce soir chez lui
les jus de françoise hardy ah ouais jean
marie perrier jacques dutronc est un
acteur blix la plaine rider au moment où
il a été marié voulait pas divorcer et
au moment où françois pas du tout la
question c'est que c'est la question
c'était pas ça pour lui gt gt une
aventure quoi ce look est très
intéressant pour moi puisque les protège
c'était qu'il y ait cet acteur il est
connu non non c'est un acteur anglais
jeu 58 tous hétéros
non non c'est au moment où ils essaient
ils étaient ils étaient vraiment pas mal
du tout avec aulas l'a écrit c'était
l'époque où jean marie périer était un
peu volage un peu un leader jean marie
périer n'a jamais été volage il est
devenu quand moi je le suis
alors pourquoi s'est-elle avec l'anglais
alors mais parce que parce qu'il était à
tomber alors et ses lacs du trot enlevé
ses lunettes qu'il a mis des lentilles
et qu'il devenait beau c'est à ce moment
là
non non non mais c'est à dire que moi je
suis resté un peu scotché à cet acteur
anglais qui était très en détectent
parce que pour lui il n'avait jamais été
question d'avoir une relation suivie
avec moi je crois que la même année
d'ailleurs il a eu dans sa vie moi et
brigitte bardot il a fait plus fort que
bob dylan et qui n'a eu ni l'une ni
l'autre et donc et qui les voulaient
toutes les deux et donc donc ce secteur
très charmant me voyait de temps en
temps avec avec jacky me disais mais il
est cent fois mieux que moi
il est cent fois mieux que moi c'est
avec lui il faut être
il avait raison bah oui ça dure et qu'en
même temps mais sa nasse ça a été une
aventure très sexy de 10,4 est
épisodique mais très agréable quand avez
vous pleuré pour la dernière fois à ce
que je pensais qu'il ya pas longtemps il
ya eu un déluge terrible et je revenais
de mi course avec mon quasi bourré mon
panier bourg etc
j'ai glissé sur une feuille retrouvé les
quatre fers en l'air et l'âge est là ça
a été mon entrée officielle dans le
troisième âge est vraiment génial a dû
changer auriez quoi en vous si vous
aviez une baguette magique au le cerveau
oui oui je prendrai le cerveau je ne
sais pas moi détiennent emile baulieu
tiens que pourriez-vous dire depuis le
négatif sur vous
je chante comme un pied c'est vrai et
même je chante moins bien qu'un pied non
je suis d'accord je suis quand même
aussi
alors si votre vie était à refaire
qu'est-ce que vous ne referiez pas
pareil je serai je serai moins dociles
moins et moins moins prévisible un peu
plus à ces dix ayala sur voilà c'est ça
marche tout le temps c'est faux nous
surprendre il faut être insaisissable il
faut c'est des liégeois titiller votre
instinct mal de conquêtes et a fait les
courses et les noms je sais pas faire
liane foly comme ça comment absents on
apercevoir situation en dormant bah
ouais moi c'est pas mal arrive moi ma
belle mère est morte dans son sommeil
c'est pas drôle évidemment pour la
personne qui se réveille à côté d'elle
la ville tant de belles choses
je foncerai en forme moi vous êtes venus
là vous étiez un peu qu est-ce qui
c'était non parce que la dernière fois
il fallait défendre quelque chose de
très compliqué et se trouvait dans une
émission comme ça où il faut mettre un
océan dans une petite bouteille c'est
très difficile dans ces trésors plus
cher thierry que vous n'aviez pas lu une
seule ligne de mon livre et que vous
m'avez donc posé de très mauvaises
questions auxquelles il était très
difficile de répondre et vraiment je me
suis sentie exactement marabout qui fait
cette analyse ahmed tessier vous qui
connaissez bien les des planètes
il ya de la vie et de la vie sur jupiter
vous croyez vous pensez à quoi là à rien
ça m'arrive souvent c'est bien pour ça
que c'est une grande comédienne nous
arriver complètement à faire le vide à
vous remplir des personnages non mais
sérieux ça ne s'est pas dit si la nation
quand vous regardez le matin dans la
glace vous dites quoi rien vous auriez
me ressemble la fifa vous étiez petite
personne
c'est vrai c'est vrai ah oui vraiment
oui vous avez pleuré quand pour la
dernière fois ben là j'étais en larmes
dans ma loge mais bon comment arrivez
vous changeriez quoi en vous si vous
aviez une baguette magique rien qu'est
ce que vous pourriez dire de plus
négatif sur vaut rien si votre vie était
à refaire
qu'est-ce que vous changeriez rien mais
vous devriez appelez votre interview
l'art dit rien alors vraiment vraiment
dans sérieux on va sérieusement qui avez
vous le plus envie d'épater personnes
non mais jouer non c'est vrai vos
enfants votre mari non r cette envie qui
le dit ce moment tu es génial ou ma
chérie tu extraordinaire non non ne
disent pas souvent ah ouais que feriez
vous si vous restez 24 heures à vivre à
part rien qu'est ce que je ferais rien
vous êtes déjà pensé au suicide
non non non non donc allez me demander
ça parce que c'est parce que c'est la
review oui c'est l'art did you c'est
comme ça pour tout le monde
de quelle question aimeriez vous avoir
la réponse celle que vous venez de me
poser
qu'est ce que la vie nous a appris rien
j'espère rien encore comment
aimeriez-vous mourir n'a j'aimerais
mieux pas ouais vous avez menti pendant
cette interview là tout le temps
[Musique]